contrôle emmanuel macron l'avait reconnu
lors de son allocution télévisée le 14
octobre dernier
l'application stop qu'ovide est un échec
en france
ça n'a pas marché c'est à dire que c'est
surtout ça a été beaucoup moins
télécharger le tous nos voisins
deux millions et demi de personnes à peu
près les britanniques les allemands ont
beaucoup plus de téléchargements
on n'a pas réussi mais quand je regarde
nos voisins aujourd'hui et les cas qui
ont été identifiés par une telle
application même en allemagne en
angleterre très peu l'application a été
téléchargée près de deux millions et
demi de fois et a servi à ce jour a
alerté moins de 500 personnes qu'ils
étaient qu'à contacter de quoi faire
comprendre au gouvernement qu'une
nouvelle version était nécessaire depuis
plusieurs semaines j'ai demandé aux
équipes de complètement reconfiguré les
choses il faut qu'on ait une nouvelle
application elle va s'appeler tous
antico vide chacun est mobilisée c'est
une application élan à regarder ce qui
marche et des autres apprendre de nos
erreurs
c'est pour quand le 22 octobre elle sera
présente et elle va comme sa montée en
charge
en face à de la nouvelle version subira
des changements conséquents mais
finalement peu techniquement pour tracer
les cas contacts tous sentis coville
devrait donc suivre le protocole robert
un protocole tenu comme responsable de
l'échec de ce top cow vide tout senti
coville devrait proposer une carte météo
du virus plus concrètement l'utilisateur
pourra se géolocaliser manuellement et
ainsi consulter des informations sur la
circulation du virus dans la zone où ils
se trouvent
l'application mettra aussi à disposition
une carte indiquant les différents
centres de dépistage disponibles près de
chez soi
la vraie nouveauté est un qr code mis en
place pour les restaurateurs qui
permettra aux clients de pouvoir
enregistrer l'heure à laquelle ils se
rendent dans l'établissement en question
et de recevoir des alertes si d'autres
clients ont été testés positifs
autre nouveauté tous sentis kovy
demandera à ses utilisateurs d'activer
manuellement l'application avant de se
rendre dans un lieu où ils sont
susceptibles de côtoyer plus des six
personnes recommandées
l'idée reste donc à quelque chose près
la même avec comme enjeu crucial pour le
gouvernement de convaincre un plus grand
nombre de personnes conditions
préalables de sa réussite